the White House making more excuses for
their failure on the baby formula
shortage as parents Across America
struggle to feed their infants
Transportation secretary Pete
butterjudge is taking the don't blame us
route
the administration acted from day one
after the recall taking steps like
creating more flexibility for the WIC
program to help rebalance the
availability of formula in the states
the government does not make baby
formula nor should it companies make
formula and one of those companies a
company which by the way seems to have
40 percent market share messed up and is
unable to confirm that a plant a major
plant is safe and free of contamination
and the administration contradicting
what Biden just said about when the
White House first learned of the problem
if we'd been better mind readers I guess
we could have but we moved as quickly as
the problem became apparent to us and
FDA has kept me apprised at this from
last year uh we have been moving as
quickly as we can we have been working
on this since we have since we learned
about this back in February it's
important to remember this shortage
exists because Abbott closed the
facility uh uh close a facility because
of safety concerns from the FDA and
Abbott and the FDA have entered an
agreement to restart that closed baby
forbial plant in Michigan but there's no
timeline on when it will reopen judge
you were talking to the break that you
have no interest in talking about this
this infuriates me because I was on the
prowl yesterday looking for formula for
my daughter's baby I am so sick of this
okay how do you feel about marriage
come on first of all I want I want to
talk about Karen John Pierre okay she
said when we first heard about this in
February did she not say that she did
that was a lie okay because Xavier
Becerra said what Health and Human
Services said we heard about it last
year right now we know that in September
or October was when the Whistleblower
called and the FDA heard about it they
say in October they decided to show up
in December uh or to make an agreement
to go there January they go there
February they shut it down what have you
been doing since February since February
they decided that they would help people
women infinite children poor people
access the other brands that they might
not not be able to access okay and the
Border people they have formula but the
middle class can't get the formula I
know I've been trying to do this pink
footage Edge this is the same guy who
may believe he rode the work on a
bicycle except the SUV pulls up he takes
the bike off the back of the SUV puts on
his helmet and rides to work okay he's a
fool when he says there is nothing more
urgent I know he is lying he is lying
because opening up the Abbott plant
which is only being opened up pursuant
to a consensus creator that has to yet
be signed by a judge is because the
country's going crazy and Geraldo what
you were talking about with Suburban
women I'll tell you what dollars to
Donuts you've got Suburban women who are
fighting with the teachers and the
school boards you've got Suburban women
who can't get mothers and grandmothers
who can't get formula for babies I'll
put them up against the abortion women
any day of the week okay to care to
respond oh I think that it is to me
shocking how conservatives will not
blame big oil for the price of gas when
they are reaping in record profits there
is such a thing as big baby formula
there are just three baby formulas
habits
habits shutdown is a real thing now did
the FDA under uh the Sarah as a HHS
secretary respond quickly enough I doubt
it no when did they ever uh but uh the
to blame Joe Biden I don't know do you
blame for everything that happens
because who's the president yeah okay
okay well someone screwed this up why
don't they import more baby formula that
is the secret they could do it tomorrow
uh Sweden and then England and these
countries have just as stringent laws as
we do let's import the baby Point what
the hell are we waiting for why is it
why is it that we're ignoring the
obvious solution okay so the shutdown
down is a real thing but they knew about
the shutdown months ago so then why
didn't they do anything until Americans
started wanting to put Javier becerra's
Face on the Milk Carton where has he
been he's not going to witness
protection it's like the only cabinet
secretary you never ever see right and
he does have a responsibility here and
for President Biden to so snottily say
well if we were mind readers that is so
insulting because if they just if the
administration for just once for once
would say we have to do better on this
and we're on top of it and we're going
to get this agreement done this consent
decree is going to get done in the
meantime I told the FDA fix the
regulatory thing get that formula from
Europe get it from Canada moms I hear
you I'm with there's none of that
there's only blaming Republicans for not
fighting against big oil that is so
insulting to the folks there and I think
that when Pete Buddha Joe says acting
since day one it means that they've
actually completely and totally failed
it I do not believe the people who said
oh my gosh she's so well spoken he was
so wow he does such a great job in the
Sunday shows he can he look he speaks a
lot better than someone else we're going
to talk about later in this show yeah
but he said nothing and he's up they've
offered nothing to them and I think that
this is an absolutely atrocious thing
this is the one thing that could have
gotten right you know it is kind of
disturbing Jesse here's mayor Pete right
this is his wheelhouse and he was a
young dad on paternity leave he should
have he doesn't lactate as far as we
know he doesn't so he's in government
shouldn't have been on top of this I
mean it's almost kind of like he should
have known this mayor Pete can't get
baby formula in Joe Biden's America yes
mayor Pete is not even blaming Joe Biden
so stupid luckily for me thank God Jesse
Jr is a food snob because we went
through about three or four different
types of baby formula before he finally
found the one he liked he was
Persnickety thank goodness I feel bad
for you and all the mothers out there
because sometimes it takes a long time
to get it right Pete says it the
government doesn't make baby formula the
government doesn't make anything when
does that ever stop the government for
getting involved in everything Geraldo
yes the FDA has to do regulation and
oversight what are the Democrats
constantly whine about more regulation
more government oversight the one
opportunity they had to go in there and
do regulation and oversight they
absolutely blew it now this isn't like
oh there was an outage at the salad fork
Factory okay okay you know what maybe
the FDA doesn't no this is baby feet is
that a glacial Pace under the Trump
Administration during the vaccine FDA
was not glacial they warped speed yeah
relatively speaking but it was a glacial
Pace okay so we were waiting five months
what took him five months
I am merely saying that to ignore the
structure of the baby formula industry
is to do a decision why doesn't your man
Biden drop the import regulation are you
that's a good question so you don't know
either that's it basically if this had
happened under trump it would have been
oh Trump
imported import it import it import it
no you know what look the CDC made a
decision that there was nothing in that
plant that contaminated the baby formula
and they made that decision a while ago
so this is just a lot of fake garbage
down their part not the CDC but Biden
and the other one saying we just heard
about it we definitely don't have strong
opinions on this all right ahead
pressure building on President Biden to
treat fentanyl poisoning deaths the same
way he does covid hi everyone I'm Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now